So, we're here fulfilling your Aby's
Strange Dreams orders. Thank you guys so
much for the first time that you guys uh
we did the fundraiser and you guys
raised enough for 2,000 books to be
printed. Those have been gone for a
couple weeks now and I stepped out in
faith to get 2,000 more books. So, we
need your help to to uh fund that. Go to
the fundraiser. It's on zephy.com. Every
cent of your donation goes towards this.
Zephy actually doesn't take any money
out as long as you uncheck the tip box.
Now, these are the orders that are
coming in. Notice all these red ones
that say unfulfilled. Those are all need
to be done. Um, I've done this many so
far. Me and my daughter Lily, we have
done this many just today. Yesterday,
there was about the same amount. Or not
yesterday, but Friday, there was the
same amount. And even though these are
free, they're not technically free
because I have to buy the tape, the
packaging supplies. We're using these
envelopes. We're actually using
recycling
uh paper bags because it just packing
supplies cost a lot of money. So even
though we're saying they're free and you
have to pay shipping, they they
technically aren't free. Plus, it's
time. I mean, this takes my whole day.
My whole day is gone. It's 4:30. So,
whenever these orders come in, I just
wanted to show you kind of behind the
scenes of what happens. It takes a while
to just process. So, like I'll do this
order right here. I have to put in the
person's name on USPS. I have to fill
out all the information and go back and
forth between
um the the person's information.
And because we ship it from home, that
actually helps save on some of the cost,
too. But then, you know, once this is
all filled out and packaged, then I have
to go to the actual post office and mail
this stuff. So, thank you guys so much
for your support. We really can't do
this without you. We want this to stay a
free resource. We're only almost $2,000
towards the $5,000 cost of the 2,000
books. And the orders are coming in
because this Disney Alio movie coming
out right now. We Christians need to
step up with the truth. And so we could
really use your support, your financial
support. And we love you guys. We can't
do this without you. We just wanted to
show you a little behind the scenes. And
if you ordered a book, they're on their